I'm willing to stand around for miles
you disregarded the concern of me
they're my friends out here so I want to
ask you again man do you think I'm
[ __ ] joking when I called your ass
over you what's in your pocket
it's like that [ __ ] down I'm not robbing
you yet but what you're gonna do is
you're gonna split what you got right
now just to be able to walk on walk on
away from me
now do you think I'm [ __ ] kidding
what feel like it I have a bullet in
your belly cause this don't get you on
the ground and then one no put your uh I
think you might even go for a double up
and what you think so why you wanna do
this
you say you want to split the stuff that
he got well splitting and I'm gonna let
you walk your [ __ ] ass on down
the street but the next time you bring
your silly ass down you you better back
down me acknowledge the frequent value
standing how come we ain't outta for
hell
everybody's out until I burn you then
you got no right to doubt me disregard
me out here Justin it much [ __ ]
ain't no better than me he's the same as
me so you split that down and you going
about your business I see you you have a
good day all right but all right I'll
let you so I try to talk to people I
tried talking good man and I just don't
just automatically take nothing from
unless this folder he took if I ask you
a question I say dog you here to buy
some dope you say yeah I say well I got
you said well one from you man you know
you got I got to say it [ __ ] he got
[ __ ] me when I got so when you pull
the gun out then you let him say okay
you don't want you don't want to believe
meeting you want Holland my buddy
Charlie Ryder he talk to you though I
can't talk to you like he can't but he
can get some [ __ ] response how
you and I bet you get a positive
response what you think you know so
we're gonna start off new today what's
your name then they called me Larry big
Larry it's my buddy Charlie he only come
out when he asked me you know to go meet
people so today he want to meet you I
think he I don't think you want to meet
him though you what you think submit
that money man you know what how much is
that just give me all that just I'm
gonna give you some give me don't make
me trip out man
give me all of it and we're gonna split
some of it to make sure you got
something in your pocket now how much is
this 200 son okay you go 24 you now gone
you're gonna take it off yeah I'm gonna
take it off I gave you 20 dinner so you
can get your ass home get you somebody
and don't come down and buy no drugs no
more okay don't go man go man all right
now the reason you make people's
cooperate like that it's because the
already in violation behind drop by
though see I went to jail for robbing
the dope house
not for robbing the citizens not people
in his country I robbed a drug house and
I tried to straighten it out with the
people that said
I got a couple of bumps back in you know
you never know what it feels like when
the man take your gun then I did have
that done to me
I went over you when one of my partners
he say he said it's me they say you
robbed my old wooden spire did you go I
don't really know if I could trust him
to tell him the truth
you saved me I'm just trying to go it
has to be my point man I'm gonna happen
to you
nice talk about doing some dog did you
rob smile I said yeah I bribed you
I mean [ __ ] it wasn't me by myself
but I accept my own I say yeah I robbed
it he said look they around that
slipping right now take the a K tell me
take a k47 go around there you give it
to them use right now honey out there
posted early in the morning
and I was like man I really didn't want
to go to this for now you want me to
take the chopper over there man like
that he save me any time I'll get you
those be
let me just put the nine I'm just
grounded I don't
[Music]
so I took the dime make sure the clip
was loaded make sure that 16 it didn't
one in the chamber 17 is really hard to
squeeze and I went around there I rode
my bike walk the bike around the corner
on the side of the building
I thought that I got two t-shirts all
because I don't want you to see the
reflection another gun walked in the
house I was like a sub though and I gave
it this [ __ ] go right here
it's like [ __ ] what's up [ __ ] [ __ ]
you robbed a spot [ __ ] I said [ __ ] rob
no spot [ __ ] [ __ ] you talking about
[ __ ] we see you make it [ __ ] you had
on soluti what kind of shoes I said
[ __ ] ain't got no boots [ __ ] oh oh no
boots on boy
you got me [ __ ] up on what he's like
[ __ ] you robbed the spot [ __ ] I know
your voice that [ __ ] I said [ __ ] how
the [ __ ] you gonna say you know my voice
[ __ ] I didn't rob his spot [ __ ] she
said yes B look man always just saying
Dawg just sliders back to money man you
keep the dough you know whatever money
you had got out of here letters just get
that I said homie all got nothing man
you know I saw everything dog I didn't
rob the spot homie so while I'm gonna be
talking with him this little [ __ ] go
out the back door I didn't know what was
going on he leave dog they had an
opportunity to knock me down right then
in here
but doing this [ __ ] leave I'm a bit
still you know trying to clear it up
with you then it ain't me dawg
I'm sweating on everything sweating on
my homies on my dead homies you know
trying to convince you that I didn't do
this though you know yeah and when they
[ __ ] come back
they look [ __ ] that came back he come
here well excuse my bad
ain't nothing Clips over Y alright y'all
right
I can't had already right anyway when
this they could come in he passed him a
gun I don't know that he called me in
the kitchen I'm thinking they gonna chop
up some dope with something trying to
make up for the loss he just took he
called him in the kitchen when I when I
see him in the kitchen he put the gun in
his pocket like this and he got it
hanging like this fans the Saget he
don't know I got this gun like this
right here so like I'm trying to square
it off but I see the gun
so they learn they pursue getting the
gun but the little [ __ ] got a little 25
he got a little 25 in his hand no biggie
but like dude right and I'm looking at
him he was like man you said this [ __ ]
harm Jack you [ __ ] [ __ ] you need to
handle your business
so it hood but a person tell you that
what person say that he's telling him to
shoot me right now whatever prove to us
that you lawyer to us and that you gonna
knock ass [ __ ] down for robbery if he
died God if he live
okay you know not to rob you again
that's how I go you got to accept
whatever come to you and in the hood go
and I think would [ __ ] but this [ __ ]
when I seen that gun oh man I mean
everything that I thought was with that
strong in me ran with in fear I was
scared as a month all the banlist [ __ ]
got a big-ass gun right here I'm like
god damn you know I'm looking long time
I'm really now trying to plead to this
[ __ ] man I didn't Rob you dog I'm
telling you I did man you know but I
don't want to tell him his other [ __ ]
that was with me I could just say man
this gonna go really Drive you but I
gotta I gotta remain strong on this one
no cuz I still got something out of it
I got a portion of the dope got a
portion of the money so I had to say you
know I had to be strong and keep my lips
fire and take it to the grave with this
well free to go today this morning
in the morning about maybe 10 o'clock
anyway so while we in the house yelling
at one another then they getting a
little room on the couch there's three
[ __ ] an hour
there's [ __ ] on the couch saying well
you [ __ ] need to take that outside so
he telling him what should get him
outside you good to go to the bus on him
so when you do that I'm like oh he's
like man let's roll
I'm like [ __ ] you were all first [ __ ]
come on [ __ ] y'all go first
they ain't gonna go out I'm gonna go in
front of you [ __ ] that shoot me in the
back you know so when they grow first I
reach up under my weight I grabbed the
gun out soon I get outside like I said
they get on granite good though don't
make me kill you homie I'm telling you
though do not grab that gun and another
homie that just put just walked up that
triplet he like uh I don't shoot little
graphical anything SP gonna kill you
I gotta shoot you dog if you glad I
gonna go you tend to reach for it
[ __ ] I'm gonna bust you [ __ ] right now
[ __ ] so when I go like this
he's an angle angle ground ain't gonna
grab alright [ __ ] the other dude that
had a gun I'm for the boss on him though
he broke he gotta turn but she wanted
flow [ __ ] that [ __ ] red hate when he
took off and then make it so cold I
caught him the last leg though anyway
let me finish this out anyway once he
said that he what he said I said think
I'm gonna spare you [ __ ]
it's my sake as me why you take the gun
from are we gonna take a gun they got mo
me to save my life
I tell that [ __ ] look you go that way
I'll go this way
if you turn back around [ __ ] that means
you ready to fall now get [ __ ] right
now go [ __ ] and you go real skip a
little [ __ ] skip [ __ ] and they skip
his ass all around
I ran that way my bike on the side of
the wall I jump on the bike I'm going
run across the police's that bunch of
police is over here aim and stuff at the
time I'm like oh I'm glad cuz the
shooting with a widow
they did call me running somewhere along
the line I've been dead dead but I'm
glad I think that they got that it
didn't happen that way
I shot on her out when I got it out I
told my brother I say look baby it's on
don't think it's out funny so whatever
you do you gotta stay close to the house
let me know where you're going and [ __ ]
like that cuz I don't want them to catch
you slippin either you know make sure
you let me know other than that don't
leave this house so at that time my girl
she was pregnant so I really didn't want
to disregard you know the safety for her
I had enough money to move in nowhere so
she ain't gone she was there monkey my
fans writing this out that's what I'm
gonna do I just say if we get it I
bought me another gun so I kept - yeah
the [ __ ] there see me I'll be standing
outside this see me get passed by on the
car that see me know that sentiment I I
wish I would ask this would Scott right
there I'd like you want to get out there
muffled I'll serve you [ __ ] good [ __ ]
ain't no doping ain't no money coming
back and so we're now not all people
you never think that family approached
you up my family crossed me up you say
that's me loved these [ __ ] are scary
you dog
they already know what you bought lets
me go around and talk to them neither
man ain't you but all the little stuff
you took from I say man I don't really
want to talk to them [ __ ] no I don't
need to talk to him for what you see
there just just to let him know that you
know that you saying everything is cool
I said dog did they say you don't get at
me like this point like no it's me just
saying don't leave me even knowing to
miss my name is good kids and stuff I
said no I don't give a [ __ ] about that
girl you come over yourself make trying
to make me feel like I owe them [ __ ]
the explanation ass up [ __ ] brought it
all look here man they liked that song
[ __ ] set me up dog they say man you got
a woman you going around there letting
they see the gun and stuff
you let them [ __ ] know and still own
as me
I said you write so I'm swallowing some
of this because this is my family
you know this my sister know my nephew's
our daddy
so I'm believing this [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
I'm like you right you right you right
so you think I should just go I left
Manny they man they've been asking me
about you guys be trying to make true
that you want to see it they already
know you a gangster dog I said you know
what you could be right I said y'all
come up strap ain't weight about them
[ __ ] say me oh my holla holla at lez be
all right so I go over here I see him in
our way like what's up dawg all myself
[ __ ] like I said well they say that
made me withdraw like what's up was
finally that [ __ ] like that so they like
as I'm coming closer [ __ ] like make a
wet my [ __ ] head [ __ ] law didn't tell
me this so I went to reach for the gun
before I could get the gun fully in my
head he grabbed it so we struggling down
I won't be struggling with this [ __ ]
with the gun with my gun right nothing
they come from the side of the building
hit me in the head with a board but
still got the knife right back here give
me a hand with the board but I know I am
oh man I'm like kind of dizzy a little
bit but I'm trying to hold this [ __ ]
cuz he trying to grab a gun from me I
know that
got about half trying to hit the pen did
not the clip out because I got one in
the chamber
but I thought drop the clip I can I can
do some it's only one Inlet in the
chamber so it ain't gonna really I'm
hoping that I can kind of like discharge
the gun or something
you know but I got to get this clip down
because me and him Riesling with I'm
dizzy don't from him and they gave me in
the hill with the board when he take
another swing he missed me when he
missed me being this to you I go back I
fall in the bushes I'm trying to hold
the gun but the [ __ ] somehow kind of
wait some kind of weight got the best of
the gun he got the stronger part of the
Riesling where the gun had to let it go
dog I fell in the bushes cuz like I said
the boy a heavy I'm bleeding like this
it's running down I got the bump right
here back in my ear I'm bleeding down
right somewhere I get up off the bushes
I guess he ain't no one is one in the
chain he'd go back for the clip I'm
trying to zigzag the weight then make it
over here where my little brother's dead
he I guess he go out of the clip I guess
he picked it up start busting bones
bones bones bones bone I'm sig zagging
like this trying to get you my brother
out when I get to the back poisons I'm
like just sitting in and I see the blood
coming down I'm like damn I don't know
what hit ever
let's light at the back door light the
screen door my brother can sit right
there you like myself as be and I check
it out there just got a tool with our
baby she never over there dog [ __ ] got
my gun though though he said how who
shoot ya
once every me I said hell no if I'm sad
about well I don't feel like I'm here by
loss of blood coming down
he says be bleeding right there you see
I say [ __ ] love mine he hit me in hit
him in the back with the board oh [ __ ] I
feel bad that's what makes my side don't
help me up got up my brothers we did a
scan check on my body and [ __ ] you like
you look like you straight as B look I
need the Uzi dawg give me that 9o z up
there now we got to Z you only even feel
this part of the gun is so hollow it's
like a fiberglass like it's real life
only thing that's heavy on it is to clip
my clip this long shoot 40 times I put
that the end and then you gotta always
make sure when you draw the p.m. back
daddy
it connects cuz that's how people get
him when they Jam and they trying to
bust they start jamming his opinion it
got to the eject every time I shall come
you tell you bust the shell you got the
semi-automatic and so on you know you
put it on what you want you know so at
this time I didn't know all that so I
just had it on regular but you totally
painting my shirt pop there and he drunk
bullet bad and here's the chamber
I went over there I'm looking for these
[ __ ]
so what boy was having he said he happy
I've got you dog
we say catchy right he says be icon
today
he said he's standing in front of the
front port and I actually bought me
about the goods and so they say that I
just fooled our both lines just started
busting a little jam started when
Cincinnati and the [ __ ] jumped in the
bushes
start yelling and his mama and stuff
like that and they got just kept letting
off the bulletin to all over to all the
shelves up then I broke he went your
nostril he lived or don't know but he
just pointed that I told my brother said
that they had dared me like that so we
was looking for him I didn't catch him
when I went back over there
they wanna lose like it was like a ghost
town so he figured like
that's like a paint until the water it's
like kept riding around let me know that
you got my gun I'll come get you though
[ __ ]
I just got to get you at the right time
because I don't want no slip-ups and I
don't want you to think about a way with
that my brother-in-law this fake ass he
twisted me up on him I told him that I
said well why you sent me over there
like that someone look brother he's not
the brother oh I a lot of times you got
a really remember yeah I learned how to
be strong on my own because my bigger
brother they were in jail I had to fight
for myself and I have to do what I have
to do and I know dad
a lot of times when you deal with the
[ __ ] that they call those who loom the
gangsters whatever you got to have some
protection with you and always your
hands ain't always the protection and
the police saying always be able to say
so sometimes you have to find security
for yourself to do what you got to do I
know it's bad when you save it shoot the
person killing the person ain't ready to
go yet but if he want to go early I'll
send him all up there to God then they
can talk up they can get acquainted a
lot more soon that's how I look at it
but I ain't ready to go but that's how
you got a look at these jackasses down
here though some may play they play
hardball you got to prepare yourself
play hardball too they don't give a [ __ ]
who you is and where you come from the
[ __ ] you meet cuz man I'm a white guy
I'm a Mexican I miss it don't give a
[ __ ] about that
bullets don't come with knives waiting
[ __ ] you start picking out all this
Charlie you ain't gonna shoot charlie i
Kevin are this mark
I heard that mark can get is they got
shot too you know it just straight up
being real I mean you got really used
your strong side God gave you a weak
side and strong side when we was growing
up however whatever side you use the
motion try using other side cuz you
still got that good side there remember
when you play basketball sure
you should fight right now
try rotate that he owed me that voice
all the stress depression
strokes and stuff man because I'm
left-handed brother you know that I I
didn't talk about a lot of [ __ ] out
with this literally I worked a lot of
[ __ ] asses I tell you something to
tussle that I don't have what you'd be
scared say me even been there that's how
bad it's meant for me but I've been
surrounded in certain situations where I
had to use the gun normally st. my own
air and I never tell people's about a
lot of things I did because I don't want
to go back and open up a book and say oh
here's this guy right here I'm gonna
take it to the grave so if you missed
the part that you spot the car don't you
that's on you
what you really try to stroke on the
peoples that I dealt with as far as
Robin I robbed a drug out I went to jail
eighteen years I did the whole dam in a
hole 18 everybody if I could show it to
some people not to everybody these are
some real life Ron I cut your
[ __ ] mouth with disorder faced
with this you gonna break everything
with you you won't tear the ass up I got
some I've got a nice gun in here you
like well yes sir
later though I can't you I've been break
him down and put him together
you